meine vorfahren wurden hierher gezwungen
denken hier förster im jahrhundert
[Musik]
dieser schnee und die stille ist das
einzige was ihnen noch nicht
wahrgenommen wurde
webber ist der name eines reservats für
amerikanische ureinwohner vom stamme der
abacho und damit ist auch schon eines
der themen des films we agree bilanz
nämlich die vernachlässigung der
ureinwohner durch die institutionen
entschuldigung das heißt das nichts
gutes
der anlass der geschichte ist ein wort
eine junge frau kommt obermann stellt
spuren von vergewaltigung fest und zur
lösung dieses falls kommt nun eine frau
nach wien rieber
um dieser fbi-agentin wert der lösung
des falls zu helfen muss hier auf leute
aus der gegend zurückgreifen vor allem
auf einen mann der wird als wild
gearbeitet und der ihr eben ganz
buchstäblich dabei hilft die spuren zu
lesen er vorne sensibilisieren
abgebildet sind die vorderseite es fehlt
hier falsche hinterseite das zeigt sich
gar als carrie miranda spielt wenn sie
töten wenn ich so weiter spielt die
fbi-agentin beide sind und bekannten
erzählen jetzt nicht die superstars in
die amerikanischen kinos draußen
herrschen 30 statt - in der nacht dann
sich die lunge mit eiskalter luft füllt
während man rennt dann gefriert sie die
beiden darsteller treffen einander auch
in einem anderen genre wieder denn beide
sind in der superhelden-serie evan
christ ethik und fuhr das kann man
verraten ohne alles zu verraten führt in
ein camp von ölarbeitern womit sich ein
politisches thema des films andeutet den
konflikt zwischen natur und reservat und
kommerzielle ausbeutung durch die
rohstoffindustrie
das ist ein tatsächlicher konflikt in
den heutigen usa der hat schon barack
obama beschäftigt und spielt auch unter
donald trump eine rolle und ist eines
der themen auf die der regisseur taylor
cherry dann hier eben eingehen möchte
für cheryl ist es die erste regiearbeit
nachdem er vor allem durch drehbücher
bekannt geworden ist hell or high water
hat er geschrieben dass wir vollgas jahr
einen oscar nominierter film aber diese
interessante kombination aus kinder mit
politischer botschaft mit einer
deutlichen mäßig eben ist vielleicht
auch ein charakteristikum beiden
produzenten des films bomben habe einst
sein als der film gemacht wurde war noch
nicht absehbar dass diese vorwürfe gegen
habe ich meinen stil zu allem erhoben
werden würden damals war es noch ein
ganz normaler vielen den ebenso 1 teams
produziert haben
in vielerlei hinsicht charakteristisch
für ihre arbeit um steht nun auch ein
bisschen eben im schatten dieser
kontroverse fragen zu sex reden wird
wechsel von hines team
was spricht dagegen dass die für mich
jagen
davon ist das aber ein relativ
interessanter amerikanischer film bei
dem man vielleicht am ehesten
beanstanden könnte dass er seine
botschaft so ein bisschen überfrachtet
dass er ein bisschen zu viel möchte am
ende ein bisschen zu ausdrücklich alles
gewissermaßen auch ausbuchstabiert als
ein orthodoxer thriller ist er nicht
ganz so spannend wie er vielleicht gerne
wäre
trotzdem würde ich sagen dass aufgrund
der landschaft auch aufgrund von jeremy
renner der tatsächlich ein sehr
interessanter darsteller ist und
vielleicht auch ein bisschen wind gramm
green ein sehenswerter film ist wieso
hat sie gesagt war ja gerade gesagt weil
ich sie da oben gefunden hat
vergewaltigt und ermordet
deshalb
nein